[Music]
what's going on guys so we all know that
Hollywood is obsessed with remakes I
like to view remakes as if you're
getting back together with your ex
sometimes you get back together and you
still got the magic and then sometimes
you end up in a horrific shame spiral
remaking movies is kind of the same
thing
sometimes that remake is on point and
then sometimes it's an utter abomination
that never should have been greenlit so
in order to help our Hollywood executive
friends we now present the rules for
remakes don't you know the rules what
rules you Jesus Christ here anyway first
up here's a pro remake rule you can
remake it if it's a really great movie
but no one in America will watch it
because it's not in English reading
subtitles is hard 2006 is the departed
was a remake of the 2002 Hong Kong
action thriller Infernal Affairs Monday
night is done a baby-sized aa fantastic
source material was updated for an
American audience to take place in the
criminal underbelly of Boston instead of
Hong Kong that's how that works
what's the difference but it also didn't
hurt to have Scorsese at the helm either
he took home its first and only Best
directing Oscar for that film
I think most of what I do on the idea
that you're pretty good at what you do
next
you can't remake it if the original
movie won double-digit oscars either for
me or against me then I am against you
the 1959 film Ben Hur starring Charlton
Heston is one of Hollywood's greatest
triumphs just check out that chariot
race
they remade it with a guy no one's heard
of the dude who played weird dr. doom in
the most recent Fantastic Four movie and
Morgan Freeman looking like he's playing
old Bob Marley this is a case study on
quittin while you're ahead
like 11 Oscars ahead should've stayed
away next rule you can remake it if it
came out so long ago that people
referred to it as a talkie hey you're
going to see that new talkie yeah I like
my movies how I like my farts silent but
deadly anyone who's ever talked to a
dude in a college dorm room knows
Pacino's classic Scarface but that's
actually a remake of the 1932 Howard
Hawks film of the same name
oh goody murder and monumental fahara
boo me that's totally which also had way
less cocaine get out of my way
about our fredbear emic ah next rule you
can't remake it if your name's Tim
Burton planet of the apes Charlie and
the Chocolate Factory Alice in
Wonderland do I need to continue I don't
know if I can because I might have named
all of his remakes but to get the point
Chris would be launched hit you have the
recent Planet of the Apes movies confirm
that Tim Burton was the problem not a
Priam Lincoln which is a classic
cinematic moment who wants to buy some
aspirin
you can remake it if it's a horror movie
that just isn't scary anymore let's face
it many horror films depend a lot on the
latest filmmaking techniques and special
effects and sometimes a movie that was
scary at the time just loses a little
bit of its scare magic over the years
movies like the thing or the fly got
updated to be scary for whole new
audiences just check out in the flyer
it's like versus brundlefly this day I
still will not get in a teleportation
device because of what happened to Jeff
Goldblum in the fly scarred me for life
you can't remake it when there's bees
not a bird
wicker man was a great weird 1970s
creepy thriller in leave of God woman
what kind of mother then they tried to
remake it with Nick Cage and they all
know that turned out next you can remake
it if it's an old western that only your
grandpa cares about I'm talking about
3:10 to Yuma and True Grit solid remakes
I call that bold talk well what I bet
man when I was a boy that made movies
about horses and trains
that's great grandpa send me a link you
can't remake it when it violates the
Paul Verhoeven rule 1987's Robocop and
1990s Total Recall are touchstones of
the sci-fi action genre both directed by
paul verhoeven your move creep their
remakes not not touchstones of anything
except bad remakes you really are
disappointment Hauser I'm gonna play
good cop bad cop not dead bad cop
Robocop they lacked the humor the
political commentary and the blood
squibs of their predecessors
don't remake it I'm talking to you the
guy who has his eyes on showgirls right
now same rules apply is when you're at a
strip club no touching the showgirls you
can remake it if it's all about the
coolest cast of a certain time period
and then that time period ends I'm
talking about Ocean's eleven do you want
more all right we'll get one more so
they got the cool dudes like Brad Pitt
George Clooney Matt Damon
Don Cheadle Scott Caan wait what he's in
that oh yeah all right but now George
Clooney is an old married guy so maybe
it's time to remake Ocean's eleven next
you can't make it if it's a
shot-for-shot remake like Gus Van Sant's
psycho that's just called a directing
exercise seriously like some second year
of film school stuff come on Gus that's
how you follow up your mainstream
breakthrough Good Will Hunting so how do
you fold beautiful it is your fault
well that was fun I want to thank screen
junkies fan Adam Matthews for sending us
this show idea Adam your checks in the
mail and buy your checks in the mail
I just mean this I five so what are your
favorite remakes what are your least
favorite remakes let us know in the
comments section below and tell us why
they succeeded or failed we want to know
I want to thank you for watching screen
junkies I'm how run next hit me up on
Twitter bye bye hey guys did you know
that this end card works with your phone
now I know right click the boxes below
to watch more screen junkies videos and
click the screen junkies logo to
subscribe and get this show honest
trailers movie fights and more